original film original song and for us  to be able to recreate it's been fun  me  now celine dion is just over there you  guys chatted with him so nervous for her  to hear the final version yeah I don't  meet us human on the planet about it of  course she doesn't have a bad word in  her body she's so incredible oh she's  very sweet and I hope she likes it  eating the beach would be a good first  movie for Luna yeah I know we're gonna I  mean she hasn't SAT through a movie yet  but it'll come soon and she'll be so  proud of daddy going back to the  original beauty and the beast what do  you remember like what are your memories  of that song I have been learning to  play this song ever since I found out  John Ariana we're doing it and I'm  obsessed with it I think it's such a  beautiful melody and I'm so excited that  that Luna gets to hear it one day when  she really realizes who's singing it I'm  really excited  [Music]  you